do you remember when you were a child
you probably had a favorite toy that was
a constant companion like Christopher
Robin had Winnie the Pooh and your
imagination fuelled endless adventures
what could be more innocent than that
well let me introduce you to my friend
Kayla Kayla was voted toy of the year in
countries around the world she connects
to the Internet and uses speech
recognition technology to answer your
child's questions respond just like a
friend but the power doesn't lie with
your child's imagination it actually
lies with the company harvesting masses
or personal information while your
family is innocently chatting away in
the safety of their home a dangerously
false sense of security this case
sounded alarm bells for me as it is my
job to protect consumers rights in my
country and with billions of devices
such as cars energy meters and even
vacuum cleaners expected to come online
by 2020 we thought this was a case worth
investigating further because what was
Kayla doing with all the interesting
things she was learning did she have
another friend she was loyal to and
shared her information with yes you
guessed right she did in order to play
with Kayla you need to download an app
to access all her features parents must
consent to the terms being changed
without notice the recordings of the
child her friends and family can be used
for targeted advertising and all this
information can be shared with unnamed
third parties enough not quite anyone
with a smartphone can connect to Kayla
within a certain distance when we
confronted a company that made and
programmed Kayla
they issued a series of statements that
one had to be an IT expert in order to
breach the security shall we fact check
that statement and live hack kala
together hairs yes
kala is equipped with a Bluetooth device
which can transmit up to 60 feet a bit
less if there's a wall between that
means I or any stranger can connect to
the doll while being outside the room
for Kayla and her friends are and to
illustrate this I'm gonna turn Kayla on
now let's see one two three there she's
on and I asked a colleague to stand
outside with a smartphone and he's
connected and to make this a bit
creepier let's see what kids could hear
Kayla say in the safety of their room I
know she's in the store that's a great
idea
I'm gonna turn Kayla off now we needed
no password or to circumvent any other
type of security to do this we published
a report in 20 countries around the
world exposing this significant security
flaw and many other problematic issues
so what happened
Kayla was banned in Germany taken off
the shelves by Amazon and Walmart and
she's now peacefully resting at the
German spy Museum in Berlin however
Kayla was also for sale in stores around
the world for more than a year after we
published our reports what we uncovered
is that there are few rules to protect
us and once we have
are not being properly enforced we need
to get the security and privacy of these
devices right before they enter the
market because what is the point of
locking a house with a key if anyone can
enter it through a connected device you
may well think this will not happen to
me I will just stay away from these
flawed devices but that won't keep you
safe because simply by connecting to the
internet you are put in an impossible
take-it-or-leave-it
position let me show you like most of
you I have dozens of apps on my phone I
used properly they can make our lives
easier more convenient and maybe even
healthier but have we been lulled into a
false sense of security
it starts simply by taking a box yes we
say I've read the Terms but have you
really read the terms are you sure they
didn't look too long and your phone was
running out of battery and the last time
you tried they were impossible to
understand and you needed to use the
service now and now the power imbalance
is established because we have agreed to
our personal information being gathered
and used on a scale we could never
imagine this is why my colleagues and I
decided to take a deeper look at this we
set out to read the terms of popular
apps on an average phone and to show the
world how unrealistic it is to expect
consumers to actually read the terms we
printed them more than nine hundred
pages and sat down in our office and
read them out loud ourselves streaming
experiment live on our websites as you
can see it took quite a long time took
us 31 hours 49 minutes and 11 seconds to
read the terms on an average phone that
is longer than a movie marathon of the
Harry Potter movies and the Godfather
movies combined
and reading is one thing understanding
is another story that would have taken
us much much longer and this is a real
problem because companies have argued
for 20 to 30 years against regulating
the internet better because users have
consented to the terms and conditions as
we've shown with this experiment
achieving informed consent is close to
impossible do you think it's fair to put
a burden of responsibility on the
consumer I don't I think we should
demand let's take it or leave it and
more understandable terms before we
agree to them thank you now I would like
to tell you a story about love some of
the world's most popular apps are dating
apps an industry now worth more than or
close to 3 billion dollars a year and of
course we're ok sharing our intimate
details with our other half but who else
is snooping saving and sharing our
information while we are baring our
souls my team and I decided to
investigate this and in order to
understand the issue from all angles and
to truly do a thorough job I realized I
had to download one of the world's most
popular dating apps myself so I went
home to my wife where I just married is
it ok I establish a profile on a very
popular dating app for purely scientific
purposes this is what we found hidden
behind the main menu was a pre ticked
box that gave the dating company access
to all my personal pictures on Facebook
in my case
more than 2,000 of them and some were
quite personal and to make matters worse
when we read the Terms and Conditions we
discovered the following and I'm gonna
need a need to
take off my reading glasses for this one
and I'm gonna read it for you because
this is complicated
alright by posting content and content
refers to your pictures chat and other
interactions in the dating service as a
part of the service you automatically
grant to the company its affiliates
licensees and successors and irrevocable
which means you can't change your mind
perpetual which means forever
non-exclusive transferable sub license
will fully paid-up worldwide right and
license to use copy store perform
display reproduce record play at that
modify and distribute the content
prepare derivative works of the content
or incorporate the content into other
works and grant and authorize sub
licenses or before going in any media
now known were here off they created
that basically means that all your
dating history and everything related to
it can be used for any purpose for all
time just imagine your children senior
is sassy dating photos in a birth
control add 20 years from now but
seriously though what might these
commercial practices mean to you for
example financial loss based on your web
browsing history algorithms might decide
whether you will get a mortgage or not
subconscious manipulation companies can
analyze your emotions based on your
photos and chats
targeting you with ads when you aren't
your most vulnerable discrimination a
fitness app can sell your data to a
health insurance company preventing you
from getting coverage in the future all
of this is happening in the world today
but of course not all uses of data are
malign some are just flawed or need more
work and some are truly great but and
there are there is some good news as
well the dating company changed their
policies globally after we filed a legal
complaint but organizations such as mine
that fight for computer consumer's
rights can't be everywhere nor can
consumers fix this on their own
because if we know that something
innocent we said will come back to haunt
us
we will stop speaking if we know that
we're being watched and monitor we will
change our behavior and if we can't
control who has our data and how it's
being used we have lost the control of
our lives the stories I have told you
today are not random examples they're
everywhere and they're a sign that
things need to change and how can we
achieve that change well companies need
to realize that by prioritizing privacy
and security they can build trust and
loyalty to the consumer to the users
governments must create a safer internet
by ensuring enforcement and up-to-date
rules and us the citizens we can use our
voice to remind the world that
technology can only truly benefit
society if it respects basic rights
thank you so much
[Applause]